the new mazda6 looks rather different
there's the striking front for example
the radiator grille has been
restructured and now dominates even more
and the interior has changed as well
the in coma state your car tester
Michelle says the interior is designed
for clarity everything is in its place
but for her taste it's all a little
sterile she'd like more Flair what she
does like is the dashboard where the
dynamic exterior contour is continued
inside the new 7-inch touchscreen gives
the dashboard a very contemporary look
while the chrome trim and leatherette
seats lend the interior a superior feel
the front cabin has been made more
comfortable
ala Dinks ma but it's not just the
interior that impresses Michelle she
emphasizes the dynamic lines extending
across the entire chassis the design
must be a winner because 75,000 car
drivers in Europe have purchased a Mazda
6 since the beginning of 2013 from the
exclusive line upward the six has full
LED headlights and LED daytime running
lights what hasn't changed is the ample
480 litres of space in the trunk Dustin
them up says XOXO plenty of room but our
car tester sees one problem with all
that space the trunk is very deep so if
her keys were way down in the back
corner for example she would have to
climb all the way in to recover them
can't do lunch Cleta on dande that's a
king to increase ride quality mazda has
improved the sound and vibration
insulation reworked shock absorbers also
make for a more comfortable ride our
fantasies nichelle is convinced by the
Mazda sixes drivability to the steering
is very direct and the car is incredibly
quiet but she has a major complaint her
field of vision is restricted in the
front and to go back for nicks on the
hunting Zionists
according to the manufacturer the 121
kilowatt skyactiv-g engine we tested
uses an average of six litres of fuel
per 100 kilometers
Alison I Michelle sums up the mazda6 is
a good looking solid car but however
handsome the radiator grille maybe the
dropped hood makes it hard for the
driver to have the whole car in view so
just as well it comes with a parking
assist Gibbs the mazda6 is well equipped
to give its European competitors are run
for their money